good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 213 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
scp-239 dinh a high-security humanoid
containment cell within site-77 the
chamber is to be surrounded by a 10
metre wide zone filled with gaseous
materials corrosive to human skin
scp-239 formed as to the nature of its
containment to prevent manifestation of
its effect which would result in
additional containment breaches a
staffing of two guards armed with
high-pressure hoses oleoresin capsicum
and polymer web grenades should be
stationed outside the containment unit
at all times
description scp-239 adolescent humanoid
male 1.5 metres tall weighing 95
kilograms as CP 213 is able to
forcefully sever the bonds between atoms
in any solid or semi-solid matter with
physical contact an intense flash of
light is produced when doing so as CP
213 can use any part of its body to
manifest this effect and is used it to
disintegrate projectiles as they impact
its body manifestation of this effect
has proven to be extremely painful with
extended use causing enough pain to
render SCP 213 unconscious
as CP 213 was recovered from Palo Alto
California when reports of a teenage boy
being arrested for homicide after
vaporizing his girlfriend during coitus
reached agents embedded in the local
police department further investigation
revealed that CP 213 s anomalous
properties however during initial
containment as CP 213 they purr eyes the
agents attempting to apprehend it during
the ensuing firefight with mobile task
force SCP 213 was able to disable two
agents before being contained as CP 213
s containment procedures were finalized
on 19th and classified as euclid
addendum to 1307 s CP 213 7th escape
attempt after asking for another
interview with doctors s CP to 13 for
security personnel T will allow her to
enter the containment chamber as the
majority of the containment procedures
were disengaged as CP 213 was able to
apply its effect to the remaining
security measures and breach containment
SCP 213 killed doctor as well as to
agents during the initial stage of its
breach SCP 213 at scene only a small
portion of the facility and was easily
apprehended after it encountered heavy
resistance from security breaking
through its cell weakened it enough to
prevent further damage to other
containment units as CP 2 13 was
apprehended in the site break room
attempting to break through the floor
however extensive use of its effect left
it unable to do so
addendum to 1308 SCP 213 unintentionally
breached containment on 2000 due to the
nature of this breach no consequence has
been issued video feed taken at 3:15
a.m. from a CP 213 cell Jo its bed at a
section of the floor being affected
which caused SCP 213 to fall into a
basement level containment procedures
have been slated for revision researches
mode from study of this video it is
clear that SCP 213 control of this
effect is not as perfect as it
previously believed and it has become a
more cooperative with us in trying to
establish a method to control and
utilize it they conjecture on the part
of the review staff as to possibilities
of what would occur should the effect
trigger accidentally including a CP 213
self vaporizing are noted as being
particularly useful in this regard
addendum to 1309 4/7 during a routine
physical examination of SCP 213 lesions
were discovered on its bank appearing as
smooth nodules presently there are four
nodules placed at intervals on the
subjects back in a perfect square
distance between all four points is
exactly 15 centimeters
medical personnel have been assigned to
a CP - 13 s containment in order to
observe and rapidly respond to changes
in this condition follow-up examinations
have been scheduled ninth a follow-up
examination has led to the discovery of
two more nodules located in the center
of its palms scp-239 but no pain or
discomfort they resist pressure when
applied with blunt or sharp instruments
during an attempt to excise a sample
using a scalpel the scalpel failed to
cut and vaporized after a few seconds of
applied pressure as CP 2:13 denies
responsibility for this occurrence as CP
2:13 has become notably more apathetic
and has expressed feelings of extreme
pain from its back and stomach
the 14th SCP 213 was moved to intensive
care after being observed having a
seizure in its containment cell
examination of SCP 213 shows that
additional 10 modules have appeared on
its back a perfect distance of 5
centimeters separates each one SCP 213
continues to report no pain from the
legions as CP 213 has been assigned
additional medical observers who will
remain outside its containment with the
standard guard staff for the next week
23rd all nodules on SCP 213
been replaced with thin incisions
slightly less than 1 millimeter in width
during inspection of these new changes
the medical examiner witnessed the
incision on scp-239 and an eye was
observed watching her scp-239 placed in
a medical wing indefinitely pending
further changes to the subjects
condition addendum to 1310 the source of
SCP 213 appears to be a parasitic
infestation of unknown origin inhabiting
its body this life-form has not
attempted to communicate but does
observe any persons in scp-239 through
the lesions present on a CP 2 13's body
SCP 213
over this development and requested
several times that the entity be removed
from him any requests of this nature
from a CP 213 are to be denied pending
further research
researcher note the organism inhabiting
a CP 213 fails to show up on any medical
scanner we have at our disposal the new
hypothesis is that this effect actually
serves to provide sustenance and
self-defense with repeated tests to
determine the nature of the anomaly has
led to increased growth scp-239 placed
in a chemically induced coma until
further research can be conducted
regarding the nature of this parasite
containment procedures slated for major
revision ok I think that about does it
for today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
good bye
they dreams that's all there is anymore
that's all I can enough I'm an
all-powerful demigod locked in the
chamber of a little boy do you know
where the power goes it flows out our
fingers and out soggy clothes into
broken men they seek forgiveness so here
I go our mother was there and the fridge
flew out of the way mom's pretty neck
gone in a flash
bursting blood onto my our poor hands
and dripping onto the floor we're all
broken now the monsters the jailers they
hold me now and they won't let me go
they need me home they make me fight
Grammy but she knows we've already won
this doesn't make any sense what am I
talking about
mother this [ __ ] actually happened I
need to get a hold of myself before I
start spouting some more goddamn nuts
deep breaths how many fingers do I have
ten ten seems like a good number too
okay my name is Andrew and there's
something really wrong with me I don't
know what it is or how it even started
happening all I can say is and when I
was 17 I started to be able to destroy
things
just make them disappear when I touched
them there's no way to control me
because as soon as I try something else
gets atomized and somebody else dies god
if this not a jail but a prison if they
hadn't done to me I don't know how many
more would have died how many are dead
in here right now they say I've killed
thirty people but the head that's
probably an exaggeration something to
get in my head I know I killed I killed
my mom but that was an accident
I didn't I didn't know what I was doing
but actually because that's not how it
happened at all my name is Damien and
I'm pretty amazing actually amazing is
an understatement I can do incredible
mind-blowing [ __ ] that none of you
[ __ ] listening to this could even
dream of look dude when you can [ __ ]
blow [ __ ] out of this time of the
touch.you turn some heads sure before I
came to this joint I had a lot of fun
with mayhem but it's cool in here where
else will you know ignite some old
hustler and kick back with a yoohoo it's
cold in here
but we're still sharp the instrument
sharpens the blade on every whetstone it
on cars breaking new ground by breaking
the bonds in front of him every shape at
grasps seized aced sand touches in 1
million new ways God speed
no you're remembering it wrong you need
to answer us what is your name I don't
have one I don't know where did you come
from California I just let me get some
headspace okay this is too much this is
still gone just try to stay with us okay
who are you I said I don't know [ __ ] can
you give me just one goddamn minute
please
calm down you're safe here no but it's
out there it's it's coming coming up and
ripping people to pieces
you're safe now no no it never ends in
the matter how many times they [ __ ]
want to go back to square one to crawl
into a little hole and hide myself and
let this thing take over it never
happens
something always pulls back from the
edge memories fail me and like so many
other days the Sun is rising at the west
end clock counts down from zero
they keep they keep making me change
every death is coming close unchanged to
suit the world better my mind breaks and
molds to fit their new sculpt the Fiesta
is as toss of their new exhibition
memories and history's rewritten until
nothing remains in what they started but
a name and I don't know what my name is
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell
dr. bright Darius Han Justin day
the Morrigan der nom Maxon Joker Corvis
and jayvo Jack Corey Barker and escrow
knock if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the Vulcan
thank you
you